[Music]
all right have you guys heard about
magnet fishing
no what what is that it sounds [ __ ]
fun already though okay so check this
out
a florida man and his grandson couldn't
believe their eyes when they reeled in
more than just some scrap metal and
bottle caps during a magnet fishing
weekend trip whoa
oh they catch treasure yeah they got
like a giant magnet so it's like metal
detecting but in the water and see what
it sucks up you get like a rope right
here i'll just show you um that's pretty
cool you put magnets and then they like
they reel it in
that's so cool
what is that it's like a rope with a
magnet on the end of it
oh so you like go for like iphones and
[ __ ] throw it in there and see what you
come see what comes up
whoa
is that like bad for the fish by any
chance no [ __ ] the fish love it
actually it's better for them
you wouldn't believe what they found
that's a good question you're gonna
believe what they found next yeah
click next and they found 11 items
number number 21 will blow your mind
and it's like a [ __ ] ad you gotta
click next
that's what you have to click all the
way over and then you're like [ __ ] what
was it what was it what was it what was
it there's a ten margin of error yeah
um i always click that [ __ ] on twitter
and it sucks it always sucks dude i
always get some [ __ ] ads and i get
all malware on my [ __ ]
i just want to know what happened with
ben affleck this weekend yeah
exactly so it's always the [ __ ] den
and now celebrities everything that
happened to him that's one of the
one thing that ben affleck regrets about
his marriage
uh okay so jk classic by the way that
was amazing okay
so here we go so
dwayne smith and his 11 year old
grandson alan kyle the water
um
they pulled up a [ __ ] sniper rifle
shut the [ __ ] shut up
oh that's tired murder weapon dude they
don't know yet
they don't know yet but they found they
found a 7 000 sniper rifle
wow um that was just
obviously at the bottom of this little
area in florida why do they tell people
i don't know if it's a murder weapon
it's so expensive maybe it just like
well they're hunting or it could be an
assassination oh yeah
they were hunting from a boat or
whatever they're like ah damn it
i lost it so so are you ready the guns
were not loaded
no ammo was found so it seems like not
because it was used
because they unloaded all of it to the
poor guy that killed the weapons were
covered in debris so once they got home
they cleaned them off for about half an
hour only to find that the serial
numbers had been ground off oh that's a
murder weapon a good sign that's a
hunting weapon for sure for sure
um yeah so the weapons were turned over
to miami-dade police why
what a bunch of snitches if i found a
seven thousand dollar sniper rifle i
would have sold it you would have what's
your move with the serial number
grounded off is mine for sure and no one
would know you're not gonna sell that's
a murder weapon though
oh yeah you can help people huh
well no just like what happens if you
get caught just not be the murderer yeah
just don't be the murderer they could
think you're the murderer
you should like videotape yourself
yourself being like i found this with a
magnet i'm just keeping it because i
don't know whose it is but it's not mine
so the police department has a lot of
evidence money like can i just be like
hey this uh thing kind of cost 7 000
bucks and i was kind of thinking about
buying a new motorcycle and i was
wondering if you guys would want to buy
it off of me like they should be more of
a pawn shop i believe
their evidence cabinet has so much money
and drugs that's like the way you sell
uh evidence to the news
you know like or you sell to like
paparazzi exactly you could do the same
thing maybe for that pop-up
are you talking about yup yup that's the
thing be like hey got a sniper rifle
today
you could sell a sniper rifle to like a
pawn shop anyways right not with a
serial number scratched off
you can't even that's why bart maybe
should talk to us first you can't even
sell a nice camera with the serial
numbers maybe you could just scratch a
different serial number onto it
oh yeah they won't take it because they
have to put it in the system like if you
sell like a nice uh like a nice canon
camera they have to register it and if
there's no number then they'll they'll
get in trouble
they're on a database of uh stolen stuff
and then like if if it if it's red flags
or whatever uh they have to give it to
the cops
yeah you can't resell things either that
you buy at the store but if you buy like
bar chocolate bar a big box of chocolate
bars you can't resell that [ __ ] yeah it
says it on there so is it on there
really not for reason
really
not allowed to do it nope so those kids
that are walking around doing that [ __ ]
get it out of their heads put them in
the [ __ ] paddy wagon dude i still
give them money anyway i'm like
do they have a photo of the sniper rifle
they do not i think it's because it's
part of a crime they don't wanna
they only showed the magnet fishing
thing sniper rifles aren't cheap man
that's my most expensive gun yeah
they're estimating it it could be worth
seven thousand dollars but it could be
worth up to twenty thousand dollars
depending yeah because now it's famous
yeah
but also if it has a scope on it too
yeah the christmas it's a celebrity
sniper the chris kyle one from american
sniper is 30 g's oh you mean retail
that's how much like if you wanted to
buy the one that he's using in the movie
which he used like when which is what he
was issued it would be 30 grand is that
the bradley cooper one
wait did they use the real sniper rifle
in the movie they used his real one they
no that's the one that he was issued
they they
they got the props to match the spec of
what like it's very accurate in terms of
like the equipment used but if you
wanted to buy the civilian version of
what he was issued because he was such a
high level sniper that he got to choose
like every single thing he wants it
would be like oh like call of duty when
you have like high level super customers
that's not the same sniper they issue to
every sniper in there no no no no no
it's custom for him chris kyle's story
is kind of weird though huh his story
the chris cowell word speak on it you
mean his murder no the american sniper
story like it's kind of there's that
other guy involved jesse ventura right
doesn't he yeah jesse does he got beef
with him he has huge beef with chris
kyle because chris kyle he says lied and
he was actually proven in court that um
that
that's right they try to sue jesse
ventura for defamation and jesse [ __ ]
won because he was actually uh not
bullshitting about
his family embellished live and whatever
and then the chris college state or
family was like you're making you're
making this all-american hero look bad
but he's like but he's not what he says
he is yeah and jesse ventura was talking
about how chris kyle lied and
embellished this story
where jesse ventura never met the guy
and he says that they were at this thing
and chris kyle comes up to him and
punches him out because
chris kyle says that he was talking [ __ ]
on military guys and he's like first of
all first of all i would never [ __ ]
talk [ __ ] about military guys chris
coyle saying that like you know like i
heard him talk about this like a bunch
of times
um but he's super pissed about it and
then so then he ends up suing yeah
countersuing their estate and wins
and jesse ventura is a [ __ ] badass
he's a badass he's a military guy too
right he's a navy seal yeah so he's
saying why would i [ __ ] talk [ __ ] on
these guys where has he been because i
remember him um what's the rupert
murdoch no no no not not him [ __ ]
that's
that's that's the owner of uh matt
blocks i think he lives in mexico i
moved down to mexico who's that song
larry no larry king jesse i promise that
interviewer larry larry king yeah larry
king jesse ventura a bunch of these
dudes uh rt russia today or whatever
right they were buying up a lot of
american media news people that were
also
not so popular in america old media and
then they were giving them a platform
and they were all running shows you
remember that he was on our views yeah
he had a conspiracy show too there's a
show on msnbc too for a while yeah i
remember that one but they disappeared i
don't know where they are i think he
lives in mexico now wow really yeah
so he's not an american anymore i think
he's still american but he moved he
moved out so he retired from office then
because he was a governor right
minnesota
for years yeah crazy was he a
professional wrestler too yes just his
body that's why i remember him what a
crap
and he was uh
was he the [ __ ] voice on g.i joe or
is that no that's sergeant slaughter oh
yeah
but jesse's saying like hey if if chris
called lied about that with me how does
everyone just think that he's everything
he said about what he did during the war
is 100 accurate right if he embellished
that [ __ ] about me what did he embellish
about his war record oh yeah did he lie
about his world record that's what the
desert is being inferred that is hard to
i mean i think maybe the
the details is easier if like the story
you can stretch but the actual war
record is pretty hard to um
live out because if it's factual numbers
it's documented yeah like if he's been
confirmed kills where he's been like
where he's been deployed yeah yeah that
shit's a pdf can't edit it
no one can do it
stuff like that is a change for i don't
know like you know um
uh
pinning putting the blame on somebody
and calling them a war criminal or
something like that in order to like
have a fall probably happens all the
time yeah or even the other way around
like like let's call this person a war
hero even though they like pat tillman
bro pat tillman's one of the best
examples that the entire defense
department got together
lied manufactured story documents
everything
saying that pat tillman was killed was
kia um from taliban but he actually it
was a friendly fire incident oh and they
covered it up for years and then it all
it all finally leaked out because of a
whistleblower and yeah but it was all
[ __ ] was it covering the friendly
fire
[Music]
they're humiliating just because
military yeah they wanted to make him a
hero oh it was it wasn't more about uh
like needing an excuse to like do more
damage or something like that to the
taliban well that's part of it i'm sure
i mean but the idea is that you know he
he went to war for his country it was a
big story at the time he actually left
the arizona cardinals and he joined the
members oh that guy yeah he had this big
million dollar contract he and someone
shot him in the butt like one of his own
team members team members yeah i don't
know you got shot in the butt though
thank you for that
we gotta fact check that yeah whoa uh
but he yeah he did die and then they
made they manufactured the stories to
make it seem like he was kia by a
taliban guy and not by yeah
i mean because that'll just be a that'll
be humiliating yeah like you died
because one of your other soldiers shot
you in the butt and then like
so did the whistleblower do him a favor
like was that a solid you know i mean
like take away the hero element of it
what was his motive right his family
knows the truth now right like his
family knows the truth about what
happened to him it's it's it's about
just just telling the truth it's [ __ ]
up i guess but which truth would you
rather have uncover the guy that shot
him on accident i think they did yeah
well they knew the whole time i don't
know if we know who he is do we i don't
think so in this uh potential and i'm
not trying to fight for the white lie
but just for the sake of it so the
family's probably more upset now
the guy who did the friendly fire is
probably [ __ ] uh the war hero and the
whole embarrassment for the military
america looks bad yeah because
apparently friendly fire happens a lot
happens a lot yeah so like yeah did that
whistleblower really help and what was
that person's gain i guess dude the
truth you [ __ ] they're just telling the
truth
i think people want closure especially
like lost family members right they just
want to know but their closure was again
i'm not fighting for
their closure that he was he was a hero
or a hero yeah and now just tell me a
lot more about that he just got shot in
the butt no he's still a war hero he's
still over here because of what he
sacrificed to go there from the nfl all
right you ready yeah yeah see i was
looking for that yeah and now you said
he wasn't a warrior asking for a friend
joe was
totally saying he's got shot on the bus
making fun of him and i'm like i wasn't
making fun of him
that's what usually happens with
friendly fire dude
if a guy who was here who got shot the
butt
bart or joe would be like when you got
shot in the butt did it kind of feel
good
no that's not me
because that's where your g-spot is
that's where your g-spot is so wouldn't
that kind of feel good
you